So I took a look at some questions from a Korean
university entrance exam and I was
pretty shocked by how hard they were.
This is the CSAT and I guess it's the
South Korean version of the American SAT
which you may be more familiar
with. But I think this Korean exam
ranks as much more difficult and is right up
there with some of the world's toughest exams.
It is taken by Korean high school students and
the score determines which university they can
go to. It is very competitive because many in
Korea believe that a university's ranking makes
a huge difference to one's career prospects. To
get into those top unis you might only be able to
get one or two questions wrong on the whole exam
but that becomes seemingly impossible when you
realize that the exam covers five different topics
on one day and takes over eight hours to complete.
I think one of the most difficult sections
is mathematics. It covers calculus;
with limits, derivatives, integration,
trig calculus, even integration by parts.
Plenty of conic sections, vectors, dot products,
3D geometry, probability and statistics.
And students would get three to
four minutes to solve each question.
For question 15 we are told that
two functions: y equals a to the x,
and y equals root three, meet at the point A.
There's also this point B which is at four zero
and we're asked what is the product of all the
values of the little a such that the straight
lines AB and OA are perpendicular to each other.
Now if you ask me that sounds pretty tricky.
I heard the notorious questions hide near the end
so let's check out question 30 on this 2020 paper.
What it says is that we have these two functions:
one is a log and one is an exponential, and they
meet at only one point when little a can be said
to be f(t). It's a function of this variable t.
Then we're asked to find the square of
f prime when t is equal to one-third.
Have a think about what you might want
to do here, i'll come back at the end
and show my version of a solution but
first let's look at some other sections.
There's also Korean, English, History, Science
and some other optional papers. The english test
starts off with a listening section and for this
the whole country goes silent, no planes take off
or land in South Korea for that 30 minute period,
so that shows how seriously this exam is taken.
For this recent question they had to listen to
what seems like a youtube intro and identify the
purpose of the paragraph but later in the english
section the questions get a lot more abstract with
language that even a native english speaker would
find intense. There's a question about an African
proverb "till the lions have their historians,
tales of hunting will always glorify the hunter".
And there's this paragraph here asking us
about the fact that "people don't usually
think of touch as a temporal phenomenon but it
is every bit as time-based as it is spatial".
The physics paper contains all the usual suspects
but seems mostly based on conceptual understanding
rather than heavy calculations.
Understanding an eclipse,
how to determine the wavelength
of a laser, and orbital mechanics.
Here is just a glance at chemistry,
biology, and geology and astrophysics.
500 000 students take the exam each year but
around 20% of those are people taking it again
because they weren't happy with their previous
score. Those students may keep studying for the
same exam year after year until they can get
into a good university and move on with their
life. South Korea is an extremely well-educated
country, their performance as well as enrollment
and graduation rates are ranked among the top few
in the world. They have around 80 percent of high
school graduates going on to university so it may
come as no surprise that there is also a booming
private coaching industry centered around passing
this exam. They call them hagwons or cram schools.
So let's take a look back at that math problem. It
seems you first have to be smart enough to figure
out that if our two functions would look like this
for the exponential and this for the log that if
they touch at only one point it would be something
like this, where the functions are tangent and
do not intersect. So we could set our function 1
equal to function 2 to find that point where they
touch. That will give us this star equation here
but that doesn't immediately take us any further
instead we need a bit of a brain wave that we can
also set the derivatives, that is dy/dx, equal to
each other because at this point, since they're
tangent, the slopes of each line would be equal.
So we can differentiate each side and set them
equal. Noticing that our right hand side hasn't
changed during this process we can replace
it with the definition we had for it earlier
giving us a version without any a and just t's
and x's, which can simplify down to give us that
all of this is equal to one and i'll call that
square because we're also going to use that later.
This might seem like another dead end but we have
to remember that we're being asked to find f prime
of t which I prefer to think of as da/dt and how
would we get a da/dt? Well we could go back up to
the equation that we started with and if we were
to differentiate both sides of this with respect
to t, this little a in here due to implicit
differentiation would give us a da/dt term.
So that's how we can get it. I differentiate both
sides of it with respect to t, remembering that
a is a function of t, a bit of product rule a
bit of chain rule and you'll end up with this.
Now we're getting good at replacing this term in
here which crops up again. I'm going to replace it
with the result of that initial differentiation
so i'll end up with this line here.
Now really we want to get da/dt by itself since
that's what we're interested in. We can get rid of
some of these terms by multiplying both sides by
x minus t over t cubed. And also remembering that
earlier we found that all this was merely equal
to one because that crops up right here we'll set
that equal to one, that simplifies things down
quite a bit. A little bit more rearranging and
we get something for da/dt which is the same as
what they're calling f dash of t and because they
wanted f dash of t at t is equal to one third,
we can put in one third for our value of t,
giving minus eight. And then they want all
of that squared so that would be sixty-four.
Perhaps the calculus and algebra involved
here is not that advanced but the way that
it's arranged and the fact you need to
keep going back to results you found
earlier and somehow knowing how to get your way
out of these seemingly dead ends does make this
problem really difficult. Certainly a stretch to
be able to do this in just three or four minutes
and remember for this exam just thinking
that you can skip questions that are too hard
is not really a feasible option if
you want to get those top scores
because getting just one or two wrong on the
whole thing can actually make the difference.
If you want to rank at the top I think
you're expected to be able to do all of them.
Best of luck to all students studying for this
exam or a similar one. Thanks for watching this
video and you can check out others in the playlist
to see how other countries might do things.
Thanks to my Patreon supporters
for making this video possible
and a special shout out to today's
Patron Cat of The Day, Maeve.